agent brew by her if you fire him you're  gonna have to fire me do you really want  to do that do you  well I guess you did we're going to be  fine I gone to hell since you don't have  a job I got two whole dollars ah and yet  we're going back to villainy fill your  villains now I mean hello sleeve ages  between III Ricky Gigi how is this well  actually fire  Lucy and I were invited to not work at  the AVL anymore minion we're going back  to villainy no your Newlands now oh no  no no no no no no oh yeah Despicable Me  3  ready PG so how are things career-wise  they fired time to get back on top we're  going back to villainy  who qualify the feelings of some more  gaining  [Music]